one of the most used tropes in popular
American movies is what we could call
the worship of the individual time and
time again movies will present a central
character finding themselves in a crowd
or a group of people and being applauded
sometimes this situation appears
completely artificial to the story but
nonetheless plays out this pattern of
worship it is celebrity culture random
viral videos reality television or
American Idol all these a series of
manifestations which reveal our cultural
ideal that the collective must bow down
and recognize the individuals
aspirations one of the most famous
versions of this strange pattern is in
the movie Private Ryan where a group of
soldiers are willing to fight and die
not to save their loved ones not to save
the king or to save a city but rather to
save a random private that they don't
even know of course in its extreme we
are faced with what we call snowflake
culture with all the outright outrage at
any offense that and any threat to the
deep knowledge that I am special that I
can be anything I decide to be that I am
or at least should be a star in the
movie Avengers infinity war through the
idiosyncrasies of the superhero story we
find this pattern pulled and stretched
to the point of collapse
[Music]
this is Jonathan pezzo welcome to the
symbolic world
[Music]
in Avengers we are faced with two clear
sides
Thanos who's looking to randomly kill
half of the universe in order to save it
and to avoid the ecological disaster and
on the other side we have the Avengers
who rebel against their own authorities
for whom all lives are sacred and who
are willing to go to the utmost extremes
to defend a single person even to the
price of half the universe
Thanos understands the worldview of the
Avengers and the other protagonists in
the movie he knows there is a glitch in
the structure of their program so what
he does is he plays their own system
against itself he knows that it is the
fact that people are unwilling to
sacrifice what they love for the greater
good which causes the problem of a lack
of resources and the ecological disaster
and it is also what prevents them from
stopping Thanos the first fascinating
situation is that Thanos is completely
rational he exemplifies the very story
in which we are drowning at the moment
this global warming ecology apocalypse
overpopulation this whole narrative in
which the media and the school's drench
us and drench especially our children
Thanos gives examples his own world
where failure to reduce the population
has led to collapse and then gamora's
home where by killing half the
population a dying world has become a
paradise of sorts we need to understand
that although Thanos is the bad guy in
this movie his narrative is nonetheless
consistent with the pervading social
narrative that we have at the moment
Thanos believes that we must call the
population and that we must be willing
to sacrifice our own for this lofty goal
in confronting his ideological enemies
Thanos is constantly placing that
characters the other characters in the
movies in a situation to force them to
make a choice a choice between watching
someone they love die or else stopping
him from
destroying half the universe he does it
over and over with Loki and Thor with
Gamora and her sister with quill and
Gamora even Gamora and himself and then
finally we see it with Scarlet Witch and
vision you see Thanos is in a win-win
situation because he wants the other
characters to be willing to sacrifice
someone they love even if it is to stop
him it doesn't matter he rejoices to see
people sacrificed that which they love
because that is in fact what he is
willing and planning and dedicated to do
this is why he delights why he waits why
he watches in order to see others act in
that manner by doing so the other
characters have already accepted his
basic premise which is that we must
sacrifice those we love for the greater
good Thanos will win no matter what they
choose he knows that it is their
incapacity to do that it is their
worship of the individual which is
causing the cosmological the
metaphysical problem that they're in in
the first place the ultimate example if
you want to see it the ultimate example
where they show the absurdity of the
human position of the heroes of the
movie in this worship of the individual
can be found in the story of vision
vision is an artificial intelligence and
the Avengers they realize that if they
destroy the Infinity stone which vision
has in his forehead they will stop
Thanos and save half the universe but
then the Avengers decide that they will
try to remove the stone and say vision
if they can you know fair enough that's
fine but then what happens is we are led
into a situation where hundreds of
people are sacrificing their lives
willing to all be mauled by this demonic
army which comes from Thanos
the very city of what Conda is going to
be consumed we can imagine by watching
the movie that that the wakandans are
dying all around and they're putting
their own families their own children at
risk and all of this to save one person
this robot that they barely know here we
are willing to sacrifice the many for
the one it is the ultimate example of
this worship of the individual and
although this is the supreme example
each stone is given to Thanos in a
manner which is to save a single
individual when Loki gives Thanos the
stone to save Thor Gamora she gives
Thanos this the location of the next
stone to save her sister and then Doctor
Strange gives up the stone to save Tony
Stark yet in those moments when the
characters finally give in and take
their responsibility to kill what they
care about in the case of quill and
Gamora for example or of Scarlet Witch
and vision when they destroy their loved
ones for the greater good it turns
against them because by doing so they
are unwittingly making Thanos right in
his assumptions about how the universe
works now what we are seeing here is the
return of human sacrifice nothing less
the return of human sacrifice on our
cultural horizon in the movie all of the
softer forms of human sacrifice and all
these refusals to kill their loved ones
lead finally to an actual ritual human
sacrifice which is accomplished by
Thanos where he kills his own adoptive
daughter in order to receive the power
he needs to save life from its own
excess as he perceives it but today we
have to see those patterns playing out
as well this return of human sacrifice
is playing itself out in what as well in
the notion that we that had to have
children is to harm the world we see it
in the return of an idea like
antinatalism this notion that aborting
children has become a good in society a
pattern which will ultimately lead and
is already leading to the
growth of euthanasia and the desire to
call human existence in one way or the
other the story is already there around
us in the ecological narrative in
general but by showing us the nose as an
evil monster who inspires pathos
nonetheless and by showing us the
constant weakness of the heroes in being
willing to trade half the universe for
the ones they care about such stories
you could say secretly sow the seeds of
a worldview which is taking form around
us the stakes of this movie have been
played out before in other movies for
example in the high-profile horror movie
the cabin in the woods starring Thor's
hero Chris Hemsworth and written and
directed by the ex Avengers director
Joss Whedon we see a similar pattern
there are a group of young teenagers
that fall into the clutches of a secret
organization which engages in in a
recurring human sacrifice which is
offered to stop the world from being
destroyed by these monsters of the deep
and in this movie cabin in the woods
the final choice of the sacrifice comes
to this cliche self-indulgent character
this pot-smoking guy who ultimately
refuses to go through with the sacrifice
maybe that's the way it should be
if you gotta kill all my friends to
survive maybe it's time for a change and
therefore dooming the entire world to
total destruction and we should not be
surprised to see this trope appear even
if at first it is in fact the heroes who
refuse to sacrifice someone the stories
nonetheless you know reach us at the
very deepest places in our psyche where
we like I said nonetheless come to see
that this is how the world works even if
we resist it this is how the world works
nonetheless human sacrifice is an
inevitable trope in the in the human
psyche and Christianity had taken on
that trope through the image of the
ultimate and final sacrifice of the
Godman which led to the notion that we
must self sacrifice that we must come to
put to death our own cells in our own
path
our own egotistical desires but in the
modern worship of the individual we have
seen the total inversion the total
parody of the Christian story and the
sacrifices of the the others to preserve
our uniqueness and our desires but as
the that modern individualism falls
apart and is falling apart to its own
incoherence we will be forced to bear
the return of human sacrifice in its
other forms this has already started in
modern history in events like the
Holocaust and the dropping of atomic
bombs on the civilians at Hiroshima and
Nagasaki whether it is the push towards
massive quantities of abortion whether
it's biological weapons the
sterilization or any other you know
attempt to call the human population of
the future we see this narrative of
human sacrifice appear stronger and
stronger and we see it in the collapse
of the aesthetic and the self-denying
narrative of our Christian past and so
we need to pay attention as we see this
arise on our horizon not to not to see
it as one or the other as either as
either the worship of the individual or
this worship of the collective but
hopefully be able to retain as much as
we can this notion of self denial of
self sacrifice which is bound in the
sacrifice of the god man
so I hope you enjoyed this video on this
interpretation of Avengers infinity 2
where I thought it would be an
interesting thing to do as we are you
know as we're on the verge of the next
movie coming out and I have a quite a
few things coming very soon in May I
will be in Seattle as some of you know I
really giving a conference there I will
put the link in the description I will
also be in Louisiana in May and be
giving some talks there as well so two
opportunities if you want to come out
and meet me I would love I love to meet
the people watch my videos this is very
anonymous online with all these avatars
and YouTube comments and so I really
appreciate shaking your hand and getting
to meet you in person so I hope you can
come to some of those events I also have
my carving workshops in
June and so all those links will be put
in the description and I will see you
soon
[Music]
you